welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Joseph Arrington a professor of
anthropology and international and area
studies at Yale University professor
Arrington is interested in the
linguistic dimensions of social life
ranging from the social implications of
patterns of verbal communication to
forms and uses of sociolinguistic
hierarchies to the linguistic effects of
large-scale dynamics his research and
writing have focused on linguistic
dimensions of modernization and identity
in Java and Indonesia reflecting his
broader interests in semiotics and the
politics of language today we talk with
Professor Arrington about his book
linguistics in a colonial world a story
of language meaning and power
welcome professor Arrington thank you
very much let's begin with an overview
of your book tell us about it
well it's a book that I wrote to try and
address a kind of gap in literature in
colonial studies or post-colonial
studies in the last 30 years or so great
deal of literature especially in the
humanities and history about the
colonial period from a critical point of
view a few articles have been written
about linguistics as part of the
colonial project but no one had tried to
do an overview which is what the book is
supposed to be it actually it has a more
practical reason for being which is that
I was asked to do a review article for
the annual review of anthropology on the
topic so I did that and an editor for a
book series saw it and asked me if I
would turn it into a book and think he
would be much easier than it was I
agreed okay let's talk about the term
linguistics define it for us that's a
there have to be several answers to that
question in this at this time
linguistics is the study of language
structures but always
to find out about neurocognitive
endowments of humans what it is that
makes members of the human species
different from all others because of
their capacity to acquire and use human
languages which are distinct from all
other forms of communication
communicated behavior we know about but
in an earlier era and the one that this
book is about a simpler answer was that
people who did linguistics were working
to reduce speech to writing that was
figure out how to take what they heard
coming out of mouths and present it with
an orthography on paper and for the work
I was doing that word reduce really has
two meanings because on one hand to
reduce speech to writing is to get its
essence you get reduce it to its essence
and put that on paper which many of them
big quite successfully but they were
also reducing it and that they were
getting rid of things that they judged
not to be important but what they were
getting rid of was in fact for the
speakers of these languages and colonial
situations really quite important and
had meetings in their lives that was
made to go away okay work and what do
you mean by the term colonial
linguistics most basically the work that
was done this reducing of speech to
writing in situations of colonial
encounter where at first Europeans and
later Americans went far from home with
projects of various kinds involving
speakers of radically different
languages and members of radically
different cultures okay and how did you
do the research for the book well for
this the research was mostly in the
secondary literature because it covers
four centuries
four continents and I only know about a
little bit of that from my own research
so I relied a great deal on secondary
literature some of my colleagues who
have written in this general topic about
specific times and places were quite
helpful in this regard but it was I was
heavily reliant especially on literature
by historians and historians of
linguistics
okay how does colonial linguistics
influence contemporary language and
cultural differences can you give us
some examples sure
suppose they give you two examples one
where colonial linguists created a
situation where they divided people and
another where they United them Oh
perfect
so although I didn't use this example in
the book but if you look at South Africa
now you find they have 11 national
languages okay
and if you ignore Afrikaans and English
which are European derived there are
nine native African languages now five
of those are officially distinct
languages but if you listen to them and
you look even at the way they're written
you can see that they are very similar
they are similar enough that you could
call them dialects of the same language
except that when missionary linguists
they were most of the linguist doing
this work came to those regions of what
is now South Africa they divided up the
territory so the French had some
territory the British had others the
German had others and missionary
linguists in each of those areas did
their own work came up with their own
ways of writing these languages used
that to teach literacy used it to
convert people to Christianity and when
independence came the people who spoke
those languages as far as they were
concerned these were distinct languages
and so they continued to be to this day
even when South Africans linguists and
politicians themselves say the weaken as
they say harmonize these languages into
one but that is resisted because these
are not regarded as distinct languages
so that's a legacy of divisions between
the missionary linguist who did this
work so there's an example of division
if you look at the country a country
like Indonesia which is the one I know
most about these days if you go there
you will find that of a population of
two hundred and seventy million two
hundred twenty million speak Indonesian
the national language in 1910 you would
have heard perhaps two million people
perhaps two percent of the population
speaking a language that now can
as Indonesia the reason for that is that
the Dutch Imperial government decided it
needed a language of administration it
didn't want to use Dutch so it sent
linguists out to create a standard form
of the Malay language and they started
using that in their offices they started
teaching it in their schools and that
language was then taken over sort of who
was pirated by the first nationalists
and they said this is no longer the
Dutch Malay this is now Indonesia in the
national language and long story short
starting in the mid sixties that
language was taught all around a
territory as big as the United States as
the national language so that now lo and
behold it is spoken from one end of the
country to the other but what's being
spoken and what's being learned has its
origins and the work of those linguists
in the early 20th century was the time
period how long did that take before
that happened
well independence was the the language
his name was sort of changed in 1928 by
the proto Nationalists independence came
in 1945 but it was really not until the
late 1960s that a school system was
built by the government by the central
government top-down everywhere on
Indonesian territory and in those
schools that that's where young people
learned how to read and write and what
they were learning to read and write was
Indonesian so by 1990 or so perhaps
sixty percent of the population said
they spoke Indonesian and now it's
closer to 90 95 percent okay here's a
question for you
do you need to speak the language you're
studying if you're a linguist that also
depends on the kind of linguistics you
do okay if you're doing linguistics of
the kind that I first mentioned you're
interested in universal properties not
so much if you're interested in language
as it plays out in people's lives the
way I am yes you do and it is it is the
the goal and the constant frustration
because I will never speak any language
in Indonesia the way they
every five-year-old speaks the language
better than I do but it doesn't stop me
from trying good good
in writing the book was there anything
in particular that really surprised you
or doing the reason yeah the thing that
surprised me the most was how the cases
I was looking at from the colonial era
are relevant for looking at what is
happening now in an era of language
death and language endangerment the
condition of the world now is one in
which languages are are passing out of
use by the scores there might be 6,000
languages spoken now in 40 years there
might be 2,000 so it's a it's it's like
biodiversity linguistic diversity but in
any case linguists who are working now
to try and save languages keep them from
dying sometimes find themselves in
situations that are curiously like those
of their colonial era predecessors in
terms of the effects of the decisions
they make about how they're going to
write languages down so so there are
ways in which I mean the last chapter of
the book is really addressed to them
just saying if you look at your
predecessors maybe you can take some
lessons from inadvertent consequences of
their work that was the thing that
surprised so you mentioned these
languages are dying off is it because
literally the people who speak them are
dying off sometimes yeah and and then
sure we can should we be concerned but
these languages are disappearing forever
my answer you want surprising my answer
my answer is yes some languages are
dying because the people are dying I
mean that's happened for many years I
mean genocide kills languages and not
just groups but many more languages are
dying because of let's call it
globalization so in a language like
Indonesian for instance will probably be
responsible for the death of 250 300
languages in the next two generations
and that's happening it's not that
anybody's forcing people not to speak
the local ethnic language it's a kids
you know they
were the opportunities that they want
are they want to move perhaps of the
city they want a job that earns money
rather than working on a farm that
requires Indonesian in some cases
parents will actually require their
children to speak Indonesian or it could
be Spanish in Latin America or Russian
in the former Soviet empire the large
national languages are the ones that are
sort of taking over so there's no it's
hard to point at people and saying that
they are engaging in coercion but there
are times when you have to wonder if
people are really they have a choice in
the matter
and those are the situations that a
linguist or a linguist like me in any
case is concerned about if people don't
know that there's a chance that they
could save their language well then they
don't have that option if if a linguist
can come and say here's we can show you
how to write your language or we can
help you document it on videotape and if
you offer that option to people and they
want to make use of it well that's a
good thing
sure so the strategy would be not to
tell people to save their languages but
to show them how to do it if they want
and conclusions in your book well in
some ways I suppose that was the
conclusion that it's it's a mistake to
look back 80 or 100 years and think
we're different from that now and we
know more and we don't make those
mistakes that we have habits of thought
when it comes to language and we have a
be very easily mistake the differences
between what it is to speak a language
and to read and write it and always
making those mistakes and they're always
bringing about consequences that we
should at least recognize whether or not
we want them to happen so that's it's a
very simple conclusion but it is kind of
broad units effects okay very good thank
you so much for being here today with us
and sharing some of your work thank you
is my pleasure for more information
about Professor Arrington and his
research please visit our website at
yale.edu backslash macmillan report be
sure to join us again for another
episode
of the Macmillan report made possible
through funding from the Whitney and
Betty Macmillan Center for International
and area studies at Yale